ごんにぢははじめしゃちょーです
あのですねぇ...フフッ..
フッ...あのもうお気づきの方も
多いと思うんですけどもぉ
まぁなかなか普通の人がしないようなことを
最近ちょっとしてしまいまして(いつもだけど)
まあ 端的に言いましょう
『「記憶喪失」』です
ピテッ
3日間くらい前に僕動画出したんですよォ
「あの機能が、ついに1つに!?
史上最強のシャーペン現る。」つってめっちゃどや顔で
こう、シャー ペン出してる動画出したんですよ
TwitterとかなんかYouTubeのコメント欄で
何か不思議なコメントが沢山きてるなーって思って
よく見てみると
おん？
いや、レぺゼン地球は世界一じゃない
ハジメィンこれ昔やったことあるよとか
はじめん、あれこれ前もやったような気がと思って
は!?って思って
いやいやいやオレンズが
オレンズがそんな高機能に
なってたなんて俺見たことなくて!!
すごいと思ったから史上最強のシャーペンです
って紹介したのにと思ったら...
あの～
デーーーーイ!!
完全に記憶喪失です。
やばいよ!
誰かと動画のネタが被ったならともかく
僕自分の動画のネタと被ったわけですよ
ヤバい!もうほんとに
マッキー(末期)！
ヤバくない？本当に...
ヤバに...え、2 年前じゃん!
2年前と被ってんだよ..
まてまて、2年前ならさすがに忘r...
さすがにねぇ、さすがに
自分がやったことは忘れんと思うんだよな
ちょうど2年前だなぁ
ハッハッハwww まって
すごい!!
今見返しても全く同じこと言ってるw
ここが尖(とが)ってるから結構製図系かしらね
やはり製図用シャーペンよりのこのﾁｮｯﾄ出てる感じ
ぺんてるさんが出してるシャーペンの
最高峰クラスのシャーペンらしいです
貴方もぺんてる最高峰のシャープペンシルオーナーに
最高峰なのぉ?
シャー芯が折れないオレンズ(?)
かつ、無限に書き続けることができる
機能を合体したのが
オレンズ、ネロらしいです。
シャー芯が折れなくて1回ノックするだけで
永遠に書き続けられる
もう最強のシャーペンらしいです。
スマッシュを放出させる書きやすさですね
なんか個人的にはスマッシュな感覚を
感じることができました
でネロっていう言葉はイタリア語で
【黒】って意味らしいです
ネロって【黒】という意味らしいですねイタリア語で
こんなの使ってたらマジ
もッ、モテるぜぇ?///
黒いシャーペンの男いたらどうするよ？
女の子のみんな？
これでしょ？
せやろ？？
オレンズネロは芯を出さないで書く
シャープペンシルです
しゃぁぷぺんすぃるです(2回目)
まあ!すごい!!
3日前にだしたやつでも何かスマッシュ
並みに書きやすいみたいなこと言ってて
2年前にも全く同じことを言ってるんですよ
スマッシュ並みに書きやすいって
うわ全く同じこと言ってる
黒いシャーペンは惚れる
っていうことを全く同じこと言ってる
こんなん使ったらマジ も、モテるぜ?///
めっちゃかっこいいじゃんこれ
黒いシャーペンの男いたらどうするよ？
女の子のみんな？
これでしょ？
せやろ？
いやすごいわ自分で見て震えたんだけども
あの本当に狙ってないんですよ(迫真)
3日前は本気でオレンズネロめっちゃいい
シャーペンじゃん紹介しようと思って
オレンズの機能と書き続けられる機能が足されて
すごいなーって思ったのをそのまま言ったら
2年前に全く同じことを言ってるっていう
俺やばいかな
なんかド忘れとかの次元じゃないんだよな
完全に脳みそから抜けてるんだよな...
いやビビったマジで
いま改めて2年前の見たんですけど
言ってることがほとんど一緒!!
ほんとに一緒!!
えぇ...(だはじめ)
え？
ええええええ 俺大丈夫かな頭
やっぱねこう、あのーー、
あの僕YouTubeやってきてもう
6,7年経ってるわけですよ
俺動画何本撮ったんだろう？
メインチャンネルでも2,000本近く撮って
サブでも1,000本撮ってるんで
もう3,000本動画を3,000本以上撮っていると
いよいよこういう事が
起きるなっていう気がしましたね
もうあのですね、
僕たまに言われるんですよ会った人にね
はじめさん×2、はじめん×2
あの 動画 面白かったよって
おお!おお!何ですか？って聞いたら
〇〇をした動画!
って言われても
なんかっ...
なんでだろうなぁ？
俺やばいんかな？？
いやワンチャンやばい気がしてきたぞ...
すごい記憶に残ってるのはめっちゃくちゃ
痛かったりめちゃくちゃ大変だったり
何かしらのデカい印象があったら覚えてるんですけど
興味本位でサラ～～っとやった動画に関しては
もうほぼ覚えてないんですよ。
今回のシャーペンの動画に関しても多分
興味本位でシャー芯が折れないし
シャー芯がノックしなくても出続けるし
オァーすげえと思って純粋にやったからこそ
もう当たり前のようにやりすぎて記憶になかった
みたいな感じなのかなっていう気がしております
こーーーわっ!!
いや、震えたマジで
全くわからんかった
いやこんなこと面白くてやる人いないと思うんですよ
ネタとかで同じことやっるてのありそうなんですけど
商品紹介で同じのを全く同じようにやるってことは
もうないですからね
ま、僕がそれをやってるわけなんで...
自分が怖いなって思いました...
あのYouTube歴7年ぐらいになると
YouTuberの皆さん是非覚えておいてください
あの今後もこういうことがないように
気をつけるんですけども、もし被ったら
あ。あいつまた脳 みそがいかれてるなと思って
生暖かい目で見てやってください//💛
あ!ちなみに3日前に撮ったシャーペンの動画は
シャー芯が0.3mmのシャーペン
2年前に撮ったシャーペンは
シャー芯が0.2mmのシャーペンなので
ギリ違う(ｵｲ)
セーフ!!!!
デケ↑デケ↓デケ↑デケ↓デケ↑デケ↓デケ↑デケ↓
ニュース:新元号、4/1(月)A.M.11:30発表予定
ファーン♪ファファファファーファーン♪
ニュース:よしお兄さん&りさお姉さんが卒業
ファファファファーン♪ファファファファーファーン♪
ニュース:緊急避妊薬、オンライン処方解禁へ
てれれれーれれっれれれれーれーれー
『れ』のゲシュタルト崩壊
んちゃんちゃんちゃんちゃっテレレレン
初の字幕投稿です、ヘタで申し訳ないです..